in JavaScript the thing called this is
the object that owns the JavaScript code
the value of this when used in a
function is the object that owns the
function the value of this when used in
an object is the object itself when used
outside a function or object this refers
to the global object so this that
document is the same as document because
it's in the global object and also this
in the web browser is equal to window so
if you do this step a and set it to
equal 37 and window dot a is going to
equal 37 let's see that in the console
so C true true and in 37 any function if
the value of this is not set by the call
this will default to the global object
so for instance this function returns
this and here the function is called it
returns this and we find out this equal
to window we can see in the console that
the function returns this and it equals
to the global object however in strict
mode the value of this remains at
whatever was set to when entering the
execution context so if we run this code
and you can see at the end we're gonna
have false now this is going to be
undefined it's not going to equal the
global object now I'm going to talk
about the call and apply methods when a
function uses the this keyword in its
body its value can be bound to a
particular object in the call using the
call or apply methods so let's see an
example of that we have this function
add where we pass in C and D and it's
going to return this a plus this dot B
plus C and D so we're passing in the C
and D and then it's going to be drawing
these from outside of the function here
we have the variable o which is assigned
an object where a is set to 1 and B is
set to 3 we're going to run the add
function and where you're going to use
the call method
the first parameter of call is the
object to use as this and the other
parameters are passed in as arguments in
the function call so we are going to set
this to oh and remember o has a set to 1
and B set to 3 and then we're going to
pass in 5 and 7 so C and D become 5 and
7 here and this becomes o so let's add a
console.log here if we run that we can
see 16 that's just 1 plus 3 plus 5 plus
7
now apply is almost just like call the
main difference is that call accepts an
argument list while apply just accepts a
single array of arguments so we are
passing in the arguments as 1 array
instead of the list and you can see in
the console we have 34 that's just a 1
plus the 3 plus the 10 plus the 20 now
the bind method when you call the bind
method on a function and pass in an
object it creates a new function with
the same body in scope as the original
function but where this occurs in the
original function in the new function it
is permanently bound to the first
argument of bind this will make more
sense with an example we created a
function f and inside this function
we're going to return this dot a we are
going to use the bind method to figure
out what this is going to refer to so
here we're going to create a new
variable G and set it equal to function
f but we are going to bind the context
of this and we're going to pass in this
object here where a is going to equal
unicycle so if we console.log g it's
just going to return this to a and we
set this and g to equal this context
here where a equals unicycle however
it's important to know if we create a
new variable H and we try to do G dot
bind and set a serial it's not gonna
work
with G we've already set the context to
this with this spine you can't call bind
again
something that you've already treated
with bind let me show that in the
console first I'm going to comment that
out and you can see it's going to be
unicycle once unicycle twice because it
doesn't work the second time now let me
explain these last two lines here so
we're going to create a new variable oh
and we are going to set a to eight F to
the F function G to the G up here and
eight we're going to set to eight up
here so look how this works concert that
log on a console dot log Oh F well oh
well here's F and F is up here return
this to a well this is now going to
refer to this context right here so a is
going to equal 8 then we're going to
console dog
Oh dot G G has bound this to something
else G has bound a to unicycle so
instead of getting the a from here it's
going to a log unicycle and then we have
OH dot H it's not gonna bind a second
time so it's not going to bind cereal to
H so if we run that we can see eight
unicycle unicycle so that equals eight
this is unicycle and this is unicycle
okay now we're going to see how this
works in errol functions may paste in
another example with erol functions this
is bound to the enclosing scope at
creation time and cannot be changed so
the new operator by and call and apply
have no effect on this so let's see how
it behaves differently in a traditional
function versus an arrow function we
have bo here here's the traditional
function where we're going to consult
that log traditional function this
equals equals Oh question mark and then
we're going to see does this equal equal
equal oh and then with the aerial
function we're going to consult log
hero function this equals equals equals
oh and then see if this is true with the
arrow function and then we're going to
see if it equals the window here so if I
run this
after calling the traditional function
and calling the Aral function and the
traditional function this does equal oh
and you see that oh is where this
traditional function is that inside Oh
however in the arrow function this is
not going to be equal to oh but this is
going to be equal to window that's true
the arrow function attached to o was
created in the scope of window and run
in the scope of o so this arrow function
is forever bound to the scope of window
where it was created okay we're going to
talk about one last thing with the this
keyword when a function is called as a
method of an object it's this is set to
the object the method is called on so
look at this example we have oh and
inside o we have a one property 37 and F
is set to a function that's going to
just return this that prop so when we
call Oh F and we log that you'll see
it's going to log 37 let's run that to
confirm here and you can see at the
bottom we have 37 because this is going
to be bound to the o object because the
function is called as a method of that
object now this behavior is not at all
affected by how or where the function
was defined so we just add them this new
additional code we're gonna set Oh to
just have this prop that's gonna be set
to 23 so here we had the prop and we had
the function all with an O but now we
have the just the prop here and then
we're going to make the function
independently so in this function
independent we're going to return this
dot prop just like we did up here and
we're going to set F to equal this
function here but we're going to call
the function just like we did before and
again it's going to just get the number
23 so this is just showing that it
doesn't matter where the function was
defined it just matters as being called
from within the object so it's gonna
refer to the property within the object
well thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good